let's move on to our next topic now
shall we and a new report today has
claimed that cows are the new coal so as
we heard earlier the fair global
investor coalition are calling for far
more to be done to address emissions
from the agricultural sector so is it
time we all went vegan to help address
climate change and alfred let me just
quote from this commission fair they say
that the emissions from agriculture are
on a level with the greenhouse gases
emitted by the eu us and japan combined
so what's your take on this is it
possible to farm animals without harming
the planet
um i'm surrounded actually where i live
i'm surrounded by fields which are full
of sheep and cows so i spend a lot of my
time dodging them but um
there are all sorts of innovations which
animal scientists are uh engaging with
on feedstocks for uh cattle cattle and
but the fundamental issue i think is
really around what is happening on mass
scale farming uh in particular in places
like brazil where we're not only
consider where the emissions associated
with uh beef in particular and not just
the ways in which cows
emit gases from both ends uh but but
especially from the deforestation which
is associated with that style of uh
raising cattle and
that is a very
very tough nut to crack i mean it's you
know we're again talking about one of
those hard to regulate jurisdictions of
bolsonaro's brazil uh so
you know engaging in that sort of
context is much much harder i think and
equally critical
food and land use are really you know
the two of the hardest to abate sectors
electricity which is where we started
this conversation is where we've made
massive strides as you as you've just
indicated
but food and land use are really much
much harder and we've scarcely started
working on working in that space well
that's right isn't it michael and the
the decision about whether to go vegan
is a very personal one people want
choice don't they they and and telling
people what they should eat is is going
to be very very tough people want to be
able to be individuals and
with something as basic as diet they
want to
choose their own food
you're absolutely right and i think if
we think about um you know you put out
the word vegan out there and this is
very emotional and you put out anything
that relates to food and we're already
in a culture war
and that is important to acknowledge and
it's important for us to do that and
bring everyone along with us and bring
that bring everyone along with us is
enable a transition to lower carbon um
lives and livelihoods that will enable
us to transition to net zero while
not um um okay
intervening in everybody's diet but very
quickly here's the story right if
renewables replace uh replace fossil
fuels we already have alternatives to
meet